philadelphia new york city we get your
tickets to the ayg live shows they're
gonna sell out yes they are you got
october 27th down there at helium comedy
club show starts at seven don't be late
those ticks are almost gone so get on
them then you got new york city on
november 9th at gotham comedy club it's
gonna be a hot one get your ticks pour
the new york comedy festival do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grow
up to be classy yeah or if they're just
a big old piece of trash i'm your host
age foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're down here at antony's basement
she's excited for halloween yeah all
right she's trying to get a couple of uh
she wants a couple razor blades in her
candies so you get a little lawsuit
going get that snickers money my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the ceo of ru garbage he's
international businessman ladies and
gentlemen give it up for the one the
only mr kevin james ryan hey gang happy
to be here thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
[ __ ] baby hit that button and we say
it every episode but i would be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] if i didn't bring up the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
are you garbage sing it sister shout out
to the yam families the kanti families
the founders all their subsidiaries
you're [ __ ] eight plus in my book oh
salt of the earth i'll tell you that
right now how about a quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire he's the
magic man makes us all look good it's
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up
dudes what's up t-boned not that we hit
all the sharp implements it's about to
get quick
[Laughter]
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest
back with us again today you know them
we love them everybody loves them this
man moves in many circles he goes by
many names some people know him as
chrissy new money chrissy sellouts
chrissy second show at it chrissy
algorithms chrissy cable tv chrissy
merch drops but everybody and i mean
everybody knows them as chrissy chaos
give it up for the one the only chris
the stefano everybody how you doing
thanks for having me i'd like to add one
more chrissy [ __ ] renewal by anderson
you guys all the charge for my windows i
had to drop 50k on windows oh man i got
abused man yeah they saw you coming down
the street it was one of those things it
was one of those things where i tweeted
out hey just had a great ex because i
was i was genuinely being sincere i was
like just had a great experience with
the lovely people at renewal by anderson
can't wait for my new windows and then
my dms my tweets got lit up they said
you [ __ ] idiot yeah why would you it
was people going like that sending me
that they were like you got ripped off
and then i said what i paid to a friend
who owns a window company's i said how
much how bad did they bang me out he
said i would say you got hit up for
about sixty percent up charging yeah
yeah he's like wow what are we waiting
i was like well let me call and cancel
and then i called and then i called and
of course they have uh no cancellation
with the windows the window's already in
no january it's going to start it's
going to take six months i used to sell
windows
anderson was one of our competitors yeah
is it was renewal by anderson a big
mistake
for 50k yeah it was it was a big mistake
19 windows though that's a lot of
windows but on paper as a kid you'd see
those anderson windows commercials yeah
you would say to yourself someday
someday ma someday we won't have this
[ __ ] we'll get some [ __ ] anderson
i said i got and he came in with his
tools he had a heat lamp
oh he's saw dude he sold me with the
heat light but i was like oh it does
feel warmer yeah they do that with the
anderson windows this one's triple pane
there's there's
gas in there
he said listen he said i know you live
on top of a hill but you got little ones
these windows need to be flood proof
okay yes they do i can't have my kid in
a flood world noah's ark we're on an
island think about it yeah this is stan
and i said yeah but i live about 800
feet above sea level i said you never
know the weather's changing
global warming can be a [ __ ] jesus
christ to hold the whole joint you got
the whole joint i got the old joint dude
when you where'd that come from why did
you why'd you make that move they were
pro how old's the house probably 20
something years old no older than that
the house was built in like 1955. really
yeah yeah something like that
nice place yeah and they haven't updated
the window since 1989 but a little bit
yeah that's great it's like 20 years is
how to come about is is is j-a-s-m-i-n
jasmine my girlfriend anytime you see me
adding a [ __ ] 15th show at a venue
it's because she wants to get something
done
she's ripped up the entire carpet so we
just had his show at foxwoods
he's doing nine shows on sunday yeah one
of them is a breakfast show i swear to
god i have six shows at laff boston and
then i put two on sale at the wilbur
because she wants to [ __ ] raise the
roof in the bedroom what yeah cause
she's like oh look chris you could get
hit in the head with the fan i said i'm
not nine feet tall yeah she was like we
need cathedral ceilings all right
i was like i don't want to get cathedral
she's like it really makes me happy to
get cathedral i said give me a show at
the wilbur
got the renewal guy on the phone yeah
that's foundation work
you shouldn't be saying that publicly
because you're going to be getting hit
up by every sleazeball contractor well
no i'm here to bayon well now well now
though now i got my guy a guy i i i said
this on your show
you need a buffer i got my gun shout out
anthony esposito sounds real credible
i call him
8 million retainer worth every penny
yeah shout out anthony esposito from bay
ridge brooklyn he owns badass academy
jim in bay ridge brooklyn and the hell's
he know about house
he got some kickboxer handling the books
what the [ __ ] wrong with this kid i'm
telling you he doesn't let anything
[ __ ] get past anybody
he he chops the prices
yeah put that savings in a headlock and
for a very very very small fee that he
collects i never get [ __ ] by anybody i
i like it just got screwed on the
windows no but that was just
me
i called him i called him after i got
[ __ ] by uh renewal by anderson but
it's all good we're on the up and up now
um i did have to add a show at the
borgata because she wants a porch swing
but that's the last one
i'm portraying that's like a green yeah
but not not the one she wants
it's got it's got anderson windows on it
yeah
oh my god you are upset i got the pool
closed we finally closed the pool they
hit me for three thousand for that too
much
what would what should it be oh my god
dude
what the [ __ ] a couple hundred bucks you
paid three grand for a tarp yeah well
well that uh they pumped the pool and he
put some chemicals in it i mean
this is crazy
dude three grand shout out tom's pool
service
tom's a good guy
how about this yesterday and tell me
what you guys would do
you've been in my block yes very nice
beautiful very nice neighborhood
beautiful piece of property ladies and
gentlemen what am i supposed to do here
in this situation i'm sitting out on the
porch swing with my little format though
we're having a good day i'm drinking
coffee out there um we're having fun i
noticed the landscapers across the
street at my neighbor's house i noticed
one of them uh put the lawnmower down
and take a piss right in the corner of
my neighbor's house
right pissed on the side do i go tell
the neighbor i was obviously raised
we're standing i don't want to rat
anybody out here i didn't see this guy
piss on their property
you know he probably doesn't have any
access to the bathroom i guess it's
better than pissing the street or in
their bushes but she did take a nice
leak on the side of the house when i see
the neighbors do i say hey i noticed
that
the piss
did he make an effort to like go around
somewhere he wasn't like pissing on the
front lawn like no no he went in the
corner of the house and but i saw i mean
he fully pissed
yeah that's i think you got to let it
slide yeah this way you got to let it
slide because it did rain last night so
i thought if we had a drizzle so i
figured it went away but i was like i'm
not going to rat this guy out because
his company also does my landing yeah
you don't want that they're going to be
[ __ ] on your house
oh yeah they do you but if you see this
guy what if you're in the house having a
coffee they think nobody's home and you
see that kid taking a piss out the
window what are you going to do then
are you going out there and cracking i'm
going to pay them three grand is what
i'm going to do
well listen and or would you let the
landscapers into the house to use the
bathroom because they're all i would
they got green shoes no i would i would
i would let the landscapers i would let
the landscape dude i mean i got [ __ ]
tt jerry living in my house
i could deal with some green shoes you
come in
blow you take a piss we'll give you a
cure
i think you got to let that one slide
because that's what it's like the
situation you're going to look more like
the busybody yeah i don't want an
annoying guy yeah and then i mean
plus what if the lady across the
street's a [ __ ] yeah she calls the
company gets this guy fired yeah yes
yeah i don't want that i don't then he
knows where you live i don't want that
yeah
yeah all right i'm not gonna yeah that's
the thing you know i know this is all
new for you this is what this is
that's what i said i said it's my
responsibility right now to the streets
and you know break the code you know
don't break the code don't be right it
was my responsibility hit a block
we got a nice block here if he was
breaking into the house yes then of
course taking a leak in the corner oh
dude no if i was breaking the house i'd
go out there i'd intervene
you know i mean my kid's school bus
stops on that
yeah we wanted to ask you that because
it is halloween season big season in the
back halloween are you a halloween guy
i'm a halloween guy
since i've had children of course i've
come back to be a halloween guy uh uh
because it's such a fun thing for the
kids yeah you just when you have kids
you relive the holidays again
so for her yeah we're a big halloween
and my in my neighborhood what they're
doing is called the trunk or treat you
ever hear the trunk or treat
that's big we're doing the trunk or
treat and then they said they told us in
my neighborhood because there's only
about like 10 or 15 houses in that
little area they picked two houses we
weren't picked this year we're new we're
getting into it two houses throw a
halloween party for the kids in the area
so we're gonna go to the neighborhood
halloween party how different is your
kids experience gonna be from what i
imagine yours was growing up oh i mean
my kids experienced her living here is
going to be different than what it was
last year last year we did
trick-or-treating down third avenue in
bay ridge we went into nino's pizzeria
and they dropped a cup of marinara sauce
in here
and they said here it's bat blood
what they said
garlic nuts yeah now they'll drop a fake
vaccine car
don't let them [ __ ] jab ya you
trick-or-treater to businesses and [ __ ]
like that that's what new yorkers they
go to bodegas the rite aid no we never
we never i never in my life as a child
remember trick-or-treating at someone's
house it was always pizzerias nail
salons you know it was all you're
getting your skittles fixed at a barber
shop that's [ __ ] bad come on man do
it well so now look at this now look at
the experience that she's gonna have
halloween parties my kids are living
different and the thing is and it's
interesting because you know um she's
especially my my six-year-old you know
she's got like multiple costumes she's
got what's she yeah what's she doing
she's going so first we're going and she
see my kids walking it's got cathedral
ceilings coming of course
yeah
she's going she's going as little
mermaid for the first part of the day
and then she's going as boss baby for
the last part she's got she's going bye
gent she's going ball gentle she's going
trans she's [ __ ] it's fluid i like it
take it after a little tt jerry jerry's
just going as himself
i'm going as aoc tax to rich dress
oh that's pretty good it's going to be
nice designer tt jerry's going as jayla
when she had her [ __ ] dress open with
the tits out yeah you ever seen t.d
jerry's tits no if you don't know ttj
she's on my podcast she's my
girlfriend's transgender
uncle who's a woman now who's man to
woman and i mean the set of tits she has
are natural estrogen pills are
phenomenal i just saw the clip with
ricky where she grabs them and that was
the first i i i thought it was just
gonna be like it was a hey she has a
handful go go follow uh at i think it's
t.o jerry thio is her instagram or t.o
jerry and i mean dude she's got a couple
of them i mean when she wears a push-up
bra mom cooking
i i mean even jazz has mentioned like
she has a nice she has nice tits
i said is it cheating if i blower
on halloween yeah
it's a trunk or treat so you'll be there
to hand out the candy and all that [ __ ]
i'll do that i love doing that halloween
it's one i gotta be honest the
decorations up now oh up we were the
first we're the only one on the block to
put them up i i got banged up for about
900 at home depot following decorations
i didn't even work there just standing
in the aisle yeah the pool guy put him
up we got the big we got a huge um uh um
we have like inflatables big inflatables
we got an inflatable ghoul an inflatable
dog then we got an inflatable
um uh uh like big skeleton what's a tim
burton
we got purple lights wrapped around the
trees we got a halloween we got witch's
hats now who put them up you no noises
jazz did it yeah she does i don't know
she likes carol jasmine and tt jerry did
it all i pay for it inside the house too
inside the house here we got uh we got
pumpkins everywhere you go there's a
[ __ ] pumpkin it's probably pretty
cozy over there it's coat especially now
because you guys haven't seen the house
there's still some boxes no dude now
it's all lived in we got we we that we
had a big remember we had the bar in the
in there yeah rip the bar out we ripped
the bar clean out
she didn't want it cost me another 10
grand
how to do two more shows exactly she
hadn't showed salt lake city
so she's the engineer behind this i
don't li i'm not lying dude i mean
that's awesome i love it i have i love
no opinion at all in the house for me i
look at it actually but she's hooking it
up though she's hooking it up i have an
inv i said whatever you want it's i it's
a great location for my kids to grow up
it's better she's only going to improve
it too yeah all she so she's like we're
doing this we're painting out we're
doing this and i'm like listen and i
just get banged out i mean 35 grand for
painting banged out
i mean we were there there was a couch
incident
and she was asking you were like you
both were like guys what do you think of
the couch well it was too big or too
small it was too big and she's like it's
too big right and i i was scared
shitless i'm like yeah it's too big yeah
whatever you say i'm not agreeing with
this one no well it's yeah what happened
was a part of it right two two pieces
got resected and and taken out
then we're sitting there we're sitting
there i'm like now it's perfect she goes
no it's not bringing to the basement so
now that couch is in the [ __ ]
basement i paid a [ __ ] eight thousand
dollar raymond flanagan's sweet job for
the basement
[Laughter]
people are like oh you're doing well
you're selling tickets you must be
making money the truth is i've never had
less money yeah what did you what have
you dropped this month
a hundred grand gotta be the way
you tacked the halloween candy onto that
gotta be you gotta get anthony on the
phone dude nothing dude i got you gotta
have anthony buy you all day long yeah i
i here here's here's how little money i
have i texted my account yesterday i
said hey the mortgage payment's coming
up should we sell some bitcoin that's
what i said
and he said not a bad idea
we have the same accountant by the way
shout out russell altman yeah good guy
so yeah please for the love of god come
to [ __ ] durham north carolina come to
the 17 added shows all over the country
but i'll do better at saving but you
know hey listen we're the same way now
that we have uh we're just spending it
you spend it and it's like i have the
same amount i had a year ago yeah it
never goes up my back yeah i'm jacked up
i planned the hawaii trip and a france
trip which i can't afford back to back
but you're going i'm going you're going
from hawaii direct flight to france or
no it's like three weeks apart but nice
just you who are you going with my girl
oh you and your girl oh [ __ ] your
favorite psycho i don't know hey you
never know
are you gonna do a show you could do a
show in hawaii i don't know if you want
it to be work at all now we're going for
her sister's wedding okay and then and
then paris paris christmas you know oh
paris i've always wanted to do european
christmas always in my life let me know
how it is i will but if i make it there
i'm hoping there's a wave of something
because i'm jammed up yeah oh why oh he
doesn't have he
they take it right out takes them three
weeks to put it back in my account dude
i just want i want to see that picture
of foley just under the eiffel tower
eating a bad guy i just want it and then
i'm gonna he's got a whopper for some
reason
i love it dude
french whopper oh i can't wait to you've
never he's never left the kind i want to
i can't wait to see him operate
in france
i went to paris what's the scoop they
still soar from the war what's the deal
well dude i was in power just walk up
and flex
[ __ ] [ __ ] back to back world war
champs [ __ ]
um woman the beach [ __ ] what's up i i i
went to paris i was there for like a day
and a half and it was amazing i mean we
were in london i was doing shows in
london me and my girl took that bullet
train to paris and um it was good all i
did was eat italian food though i didn't
eat any french food i just ate all the
time i had all the pizza that paris had
to offer you know what i did what are
the rice balls like over here huh dude
and it's something that a guy told me
and i did it it's like you know like
when you go into any pizzeria in new
york and it's you know maybe not to us
but to a farmer like all this the best
pizza i've had dude any any coffee cart
i went all i got was a a croissant and a
coffee and i can't explain to you really
how good it is it's like it's just
something's different out there yeah
yeah
the coffee but
europe for christmas is 100
bucket list thing to do why do i paris
for christmas what just you want to do
it yeah she knows she's it's something
she's always wanted to do and she had a
couple cocktails at the time yeah you
were [ __ ] smiling
i had like three martinis in with me i
sent her that text baby we're going to
paris at christmas and she was like all
right oh no going i got the passports
and everything where are you going what
hotel we don't know yet i haven't
figured that out yet i'm still trying to
get through [ __ ] hawaii dude do what
i did i went to edinburgh scotland on a
[ __ ] win i went i went because i was
sad and i loved the rain or the festival
no no just no not even the festival dude
because i think you bounced to europe by
yourself where to god it was it was one
of the times where me and my kids mom
weren't together we were co-parenting
and i went to go pick up my daughter and
i got the weekends mixed up and she was
like no we're going on a camping trip so
i had no shows planned because i thought
i was gonna be my daughter and it was
like a four day weekend my kid wasn't
coming back until tuesday so i said and
it was disgustingly hot and i hate the
heat like if i could press a button and
delete summer i would delete summer
immediately i hate summer with a passion
so so i i i was like i i can't do this
i'm already sad and depressed i feel
like a piece of [ __ ] where is it 55 and
raining and then i swear to god i
scanned that weather app and i saw boom
edinburgh scotland got on a flank that
night with a book bag of only i said i'm
gonna wear i packed a couple of little
lemon pants i packed my
leisure wear my tommy john undies i had
a couple of raincoats and socks i filled
it all in a book bag one pair of
sneakers and i got on a plane the tsa
was like you're you know going to
scotland you know uh just carrying all
just a bag i said yeah so going and then
i literally in the middle of the ocean
went on hotel tonight and booked a
[ __ ] hotel in scott i know
i had i had no hotel booked in edinburgh
it was amazing just to like not have a
plan and just say you know what we'll
figure it out best trip i ever took well
it'd be right amazing a little bit one
of the times i got chlamydia
chrissy's soul-searching i like what it
is baby wanderlust yeah well you've been
you go to germany all the time yeah i go
a lot i've been i haven't been for
christmas proper but i've been for like
i think it was the week before so like
i've gone to the german christmas
markets and it's way different there
than america right it's just amazing
it's like a village yeah it's just like
a big typically it's like there's all
those old german like like we would have
like you know any town usa or whatever
you know it's like these old [ __ ]
castles and
government buildings with like this big
[ __ ]
i love it's all the time christmas
lights on that's going to be awesome
catholic over there they're big
catholics i like i like to be around the
caddies midnight
midnight i'm talking to golf courses
midnight christmas eve mass oh snobby
you smell the incense you're not going
to make you go you don't go to mass
every week do you no not every week but
i try to go at least once a month that's
pretty good get felt up
that's that catholic guilt you do yeah
you gotta know what it feels like yeah
priest is [ __ ] going to second base
reminding myself i'm still dirty
you guys go to church so no i gave up
when that movie spotlight came out
that's when i was like it's just too
much i can't tear my head you want to
talk to a great movie you want to talk
about not selling tickets to catholic
church
not selling tickets they're cancelling
shows they are the they're the opposite
of sebasto manos
talking about paper in the room oh
no they're like dude yeah you'll see
you'll see any religions in there just
get bucks in the seats
doing it for the weekend minimum two
yeah they're taking fifteen hundred two
guys in there on a groupon you know what
i'm saying yeah what can you do can't
let's talk about those cool cats over
there at bespoke post bespoke post did
you say that's right perfect for the
fall too oh
lens to the fall outdoorsy kind of stuff
outdoorsy stuff you know things for like
the home bar
lifestyle things grooming tools cool
clothes cool clothes amp gear absolutely
fantastic gang check out bespoke post
their box of awesome you will not regret
it yeah they like we've said many times
they sent us a box of [ __ ] it's so cool
i got a [ __ ] sweet knife that i used
today to open up a box of shoes that i
got [ __ ] i feel like crocodile dundee i
got the knife it's got a little leather
pouch it makes you want to have a
whiskey and put a piece uh yeah and have
like a nice flannel or something cooking
real nice love it guys just to get
started go to the box of awesome.com
take the quick quiz your ansels will
help them pick the best box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month tons of different categories
spectrums the whole nine yards it's free
to sign up and you can skip a month or
cancel at any time
this is this is where this is the best
of the biz what each box only costs 45
bucks has over 70 dollars worth of gear
inside oh it's like how you you'd be
losing money not to buy this thing kooky
uh plus with each box of awesome you're
supporting small business 90 of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up-and-coming
brand they take a bunch of cool [ __ ]
from a bunch of different designers put
it together companies these stuff you
see on instagram i like that it's
fantastic given the big boys a run for
their money get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the promo code garbage
at checkout that's box of awesome.com
promo code garbage for 20 off your first
box do it hey how about those kids over
there at dad grass that grass bringing
it all back full circle best in abyss
you don't want to get all banged up like
you did when you were young puffing the
chiba no and i'm all right you want
something mild something to relax
something to feel good bad grass has you
covered fantastic you're not going to
get too high gives you a little trip
down memory lane stuff like that dad
grass is legal organic smokable hemp
that relaxes your body and mellows the
mind 100 organic pre-rolled joints are
very low in thc high in cbd so you can
enjoy the effects of cbd while keeping
your head clear we were just outside and
you were puffing almost having one it
was a puff puff pass enjoy it uh i'm a
big cbd guy everybody we've been talking
about it for months cbd's
been life-changing for me they do the
pre-rolls too which is nice height
little pack looks cool you can chill out
without getting stoned it's like having
a glass of wine not the whole bottle all
dad gri all that grass products are
federally legal for ages 21 and over and
ships right to your door anywhere in the
u.s of a right now dadgrass is offering
our listeners 20 off your first order
when you go to dadgrass.com garbage go
to dadgrass.com garbage for 20 off your
first order one more time write it down
pull out a pen and pad dadgrass.com
garbage do it i love it all right let's
get into some questions here we got you
here uh as you guys know if you when you
sign up for patreon you get a question
asked on the air um
kippy
this one this is we were perfect we were
just talking about it on halloween this
is from quinn uh what was the latest you
later oldest age you trick-or-treated
yourself like you and your buddies went
out and trick-or-treat yeah what did you
do i assume it was there was mischief
involved yes i remember
i remember the last time i can remember
is that being 15 years old and we went
trick-or-treating and what we would do
was is trick-or-treating you know not to
old people whatever but if you open the
door and you are like our age or like a
little older whatever we would go trick
or treat you know be laughing old you
know and then you know gets the candy
and then as we were walking down
somebody was there with just an egg and
then [ __ ]
throw eggs in people's houses they
opened the door then here's the mystery
hold on would you wait for the candy oh
yeah so you get the candy thank you and
as soon as that as soon as you're
starting to walk away you just would
fire one in there somebody would fire an
egg in there then what we would then
what we would do is we would do is we
would throw bottles of ketchup this is a
dumb thing we would do we would throw a
bottle of ketchup like a glass bottle of
ketchup at a bus window and then let the
ketchup smear all over and then watch
the bus driver just try to wipe it off
and then just get catchable like the
windshield yeah we would be idiots holy
[ __ ]
he probably thought he hit somebody
killed them they're my friend
then my friend jimmy used to and again
this was just par for the course back
then would just dip eggs or sha spray
nair on eggs which is a hair removal
yeah and then throw eggs into a crowd so
some kid probably got a [ __ ] bald
spot yeah yeah yeah you know and if you
have a bald spot check out keeps.com
[Laughter]
we're a roman company yeah oh roman
sorry um but but but that's like the
mischief i would get or remember one of
my you know we would get hit with um uh
the sock filled with batteries and
things like that we would get a lot of
that a lot there was a lot of people
where did you grow up the thunder dome
no my neighborhood was big on batteries
you would get
you would go oh the older kids would
[ __ ] you up you would get hit with i i
got hit with so many [ __ ] batters i'm
being like crazy amounts of batteries
yeah yeah so but i remember
trick-or-treating see the thing is with
me is there was a lot of puerto ricans
living in my neighborhood too so like
you would get like dude there was times
i remember you go trick-or-treating you
would get like a piece of chicken yeah
you know you would get a wild [ __ ] yeah
plantains yeah yeah yeah
that's probably awesome
yeah walking out with a two-piece
walking down the street with a thigh
dude i grew up in a neighborhood too
where you would get a lot of homemade
sweets
i remember getting little
not even a trick-or-treat like the trunk
or treat is for that reason is the truck
or treat uh does it say no
trick-or-treat cause the covet no this
what is this even happened like two
years ago because uh my nieces and
nephews were doing a trunk or treat is
like you meet up in a field like a
soccer field or whatever and like
whatever like the parents from the
school everybody brings a car you back
into a circle right so it's like one big
circle everybody's cars and you're like
backed up your trunk and then they open
it up and they decorate it they'll play
like spooky music hang cobwebs okay
that's cute so the kids aren't off on
their own there's a lot of chaperones
and they're not just like i mean you got
to do the basic trick-or-treating
whether you're with the kid or not a
little bit even even if like my
brother's family and their neighborhood
last year they brought everything out to
the end of the driveway and had a little
table set up a little fire
cider it was [ __ ] chill yeah dude you
know what i like too uh the neighborhood
and they said that all the parents now
when we go do this trunk or treat when
we go around to the houses do a little
trick street houses everybody's got a
little flask everyone drinks it everyone
drinks and walks so it's nice let me ask
you this my dad would drink and drive it
was big oh baby it was like him and four
other dads in a jeep just wailing beers
since it is trunk or treat are you
confident that you're going to have the
sharpest whip in the circle or no not
even close
some dudes on those
probably dunk on you yeah yeah yeah yeah
no oh [ __ ] do they because we made the
wrong turn the one you got the king of
the neighborhood not even close but i'm
a [ __ ] pig in the neighborhood yeah
that one house we drove by where it was
the gps was telling us it was oh yeah
that's right it was down off the other
side of that street i'm like there's no
[ __ ] way this is chrissy's house this
is huge
rental lamborghini just for halloween or
something like that [ __ ] [ __ ] dude i
want to do checks on these [ __ ] i
want to do trump retreat
[ __ ] give you a [ __ ] trump
pamphlet
on how to get our country back or you
want a candy
trump pamela in the worthers yeah
all right i'll take the pamphlet yeah
what were some of the costumes growing
up
costumes sports sport big sports jersey
was always you throw a jersey on you
throw a jersey on jersey
it's seven o'clock at night but it's
like they're playing a sunny afternoon
sorry yeah it's ridiculous cleats stupid
um walking around school in cleveland
yeah
white house what else one time one of my
friends went as dr phil that was awesome
as a kid uh i mean we were a teenager
whenever dr phil became pompous
did he shave his head or something no no
because because what the costume was is
my friend went to dr phil and then keep
in mind this is whenever it was late 90s
then my other friend went as oprah in
full blackface which is like you know
he's a sanitation worker but it's like
it's one of those things where like at
that time everyone's like this is great
yeah well that's like when trudeau got
caught it was like that was you know yes
but i still never did it i'm not saying
what i'm saying of course i wasn't doing
it but it wasn't like if you're at a
halloween party and someone showed up
you would just be like ah it's a little
wacky yeah it's someone it was a
different time i don't think i ever
remember seeing that in person
yeah i saw it i remember this the one is
dr phil and oprah i remember it vividly
going out doctor
just pegged me with a [ __ ] nine volt
yeah
be on the lookout
man look out that was good yeah that
that i can't remember i saw a pretty
cool costume in 2019 i saw a guy when he
his whole family went as like the cast
of aladdin he was the genie his wife was
jasmine um then his two kids one was a
lad and then he had uh like um uh his
baby dressed as a monkey i think i've
seen this they like made like a car a
flying carpet that's a little crazy it
was i mean yeah it was a little much but
it was pretty that's the same guy that
murders the whole family i'm walking in
the halloween parade this year you can
real halloween parade is the only parade
in the city that one in the city you can
walk in it anybody can walk there's no
you don't have to have a pass you just
have to exactly give you the keys to the
city you're walking away you're walking
down third avenue yeah you don't have to
know where to enter if you know the
right police
ask for o'malley hold on are you
bringing the kids to that no no this is
an adult my mom's going to watch the
kids it's just an adult thing yeah
that's kind of that's a crazy vibe i
mean dude yeah you and your girlfriend
kid around all those gays
no i'm kidding she's gay my kid came out
as gay and sick
good for who cares dude [ __ ] scissor
a little bit um
i um yeah we're gonna go with our
friends and we're all gonna go in
costumes where like one like row of
people we're like we're all wearing the
same costume you can't see our faces so
we're gonna go as uh the robot guy from
futurama what's his name mr robot
oh bender bender you're all going as
bender all going as bender wow i didn't
love the idea either but i said [ __ ] it
would do it it's a reason to drink my
mom we already got the babysitter yeah
are you going to dress up for the trunk
or treat oh jazz make you dress up yeah
i'm gonna we're go i'm going as um as uh
uh the uh like the we're all going me
and her going as they're like the guy
you see at a car wash
you know what i mean that that thing
yeah that's that's my daughter picked it
so we said find that daddy's got to
dress up come on what am i going to not
dress up in the [ __ ] night
she doesn't wait until she finds out
when i you know i also me and ian fine
dance dress up
at port authority we do another type of
dress up there one day she'll find out
about in the documentary
after i've had my body's found hanging
from a ceiling fan at the ramada yes i
had to add a show at the comedy works
if he only didn't had that fourth show
he would have been home safe totally
okay let's talk about my fitness pal my
fitness pal i don't mean my fitness pal
i mean my fitness pal love it all right
i'm starting to work out i'm trying to
get things in shape my fitness pal can
help you achieve your goals yeah guys
it's not like a rigid diet plan instead
you gradually learn from personalized
data what works for you there you go you
know what i mean it takes in a lot of
input custom shoots it back out uh your
version of healthy looks different from
my version of healthy me and you don't
have the same fitness goals yeah i want
to get a little tighter you know what i
mean maybe make the brajol a little
bigger for 84 people
and with myfitnesspal i believe you can
do it
um the app has a premium membership we
have well they gave us one they set us
up it's got the tools and expert
guidance to help you reach your personal
goals your way
um and with myfitnesspal you're not
going to do it alone you have access to
a guided daily workout plan meal plan
written by dietitian exercise scientist
plus support from other members that
share the same goals and expectations
garbage.myfitnesspal.com code garbage
for a free one-month trip membership
trial
garbage.myfitnesspal.com get a one month
premium free membership one more time
garbage.myfitnesspal.com kippy forget
the copy forget the script let's talk
about butcher box because i got a fridge
full of meat baby and i'm cruising
through it i'm talking organic are they
i mean grass-fed grass-finished beef
steak tips uh new york strip steaks a
whole chicken i got two whole chickies
you got the alaskans fresh fresh guys
sockeye salmon uh this is crazy the
stuff that they're sending
should be illegal i don't know how
they're getting away with it the stuff
that they said bananas how much they
sent yeah plus they got that ground beef
deal for the life of the membership i
know so for the life for a limited time
butcher box is giving new members two
pounds of free ground beef in every
order for the life of your membership
that is bonk they make a nice burger too
it's the deep red color it's perfect
it's perfect in the microwave imagine
never have to shop for ground beef again
this deal is a no-brainer yeah uh once
signed up you choose your box and
delivery frequency they offer five boxes
four curated box options as well as the
popular custom box so you get exactly
what you want whatever the big man wants
there you go the big man guests fake
tips are tight i keep you head to toe
and ground beef daddy oh yes you do i
got a fridge full of meat baby just for
the [ __ ] i got one too it's fantastic
got some stews going the whole pork the
thing we broke out the crock pot did it
did a nice stew up i did it in tips i
did it in the bathtub a little bit of
hot water
this is your chance to never have to
shop for ground beef again that's right
butcher box is giving new members free
ground beef for life sign up at
butcherbox.com ayg and get two pounds of
ground beef free in every order for the
life of your membership log on to
butcherbox.com ayg to claim this deal
now do it back to the show seven shows
is too much i'll tell you that in a
weekend it's two months that's crazy on
a saturday never i won't do it again all
right so what are you doing a late one
or an early one four o'clock seven
o'clock nine o'clock well the matinee
the never good for comedy
dude it was it's it's so i got to slow
down i had no voice you're also i'm sure
you're probably transitioning to bigger
venues you're in that point where you're
like yeah i'm not that doing nine shows
in a weekend's [ __ ] yeah where it's
like though
yeah they're like don't worry 2022 it's
a lot easier it'll just be one show at
the bigger theater and then way less
money
[ __ ] shut down again
gotta watch out for that lambda variant
kid's on the edge i like it no we need
the lambda oh yeah
just i told him just give me a couple of
months but wait but you can't see you
see how he responded about christmas the
whole point is it's christmas time
that's what it is yeah but the us is
just started letting tourists you know
they will only start living november 1st
europeans have been letting tourists
american tourism yes uh they're uh they
when i was there actually the last time
i was there it switched while i was
there you were able to come in and then
without uh
but then i think but it's different
because i'm my wife with like i'm coming
in with my wife so it's like coming with
a family citizen yeah um he's got an
inside guy but when i was there it
changed that
uh you couldn't just go as a tourist
right more but now you can i think you
can go back yeah you just go as long as
you got a vax you can just go yeah
vaccine you got to show a test seven you
have to so you're gonna have to get a
test no matter what
yeah both ways yeah both ways
yeah [ __ ] they wanted to come back to
the united states i had to get one and
then they've called me twice since i've
been here why new york city or new york
state just to make sure you were
recently in a high traffic you know a
high in whatever area high infection how
are you feeling yeah i'm like i'm
vaccinated i provided a test and she's
like okay and then she called me again
i'm like you got to stop calling what
are we doing here yeah yeah i'm like do
you even know where i was and she goes
no we just have it on a list that you
wearing somewhere so just don't pick up
the phone i'm not oh i don't know i
thought it was industry it was a 212
number oh yeah yeah i got excited i
thought it was the suits yeah i thought
it was [ __ ] comedy central to
somebody yeah boys what do you got we're
in
duh yeah very nice
um all right this one's coming up you're
a good tip for yourself this is from uh
blue collar bozo they throw about 35
all right what a restaurant i throw 35
cooking if they recognize me it goes 45
you have to yeah you're at the point
where you get recognized you have to if
you get recognized you got to throw 45.
you get recognized and you're we get
recognized that we're still bozo so it's
fine they're like oh here's free
mozzarella
no i get recognized you know it yeah
it's it's it's a little thing where it's
like uh oh i gotta [ __ ] especially in
new york staten island bay ridge you're
probably getting popped all the time is
this no matter what no matter what the
service is like what the food's like
doesn't matter
yeah if the service is bad i just will
never go in there again but it's like
the thing is colin quinn told me once
he's like you always got to give i'm
sorry no he's already lying he goes you
always got to give people you know tip
them well if they if they recognize you
remember you because then that whole
restaurant will be fans they'll always
go to your show and you always got if
somebody stops you
uh for you know and recognizes you
always give them five seconds of your
time to take a picture say hello because
five seconds of your just five seconds
of your life you're gonna make a fan for
life but if you if you don't give them
just five seconds you're gonna lose the
fan for life so i always remember that
that's right yeah yeah that's [ __ ]
cool so i [ __ ] i mean but listen dude
40 you know what i mean i i'm going to
lose the house yeah yeah that's also
what i'm going to lose so he was saying
do you are you getting sometimes when
they recognize you getting the hook up
you getting an nap you're getting a
dessert uh
it it it depends around the book is for
the table usually it depends like um i
was just at uh uh kettle black which is
on staten island having food with my
daughter and um and uh we got recognized
and and the guy the guy said my daughter
could pick a dessert oh that's nice
that's class that's a close
that's 45. he got 50.
he got half the check he got half the
check you got to hit him up yeah yep the
check came out 250 i gave him a hunch
are you doing cash your card now uh it
depends on how much merch i sold the
weekend before because last time you
were here you lie it was you had a lot
and you were lying about it what do you
have on you now
cash cash wise
what do i have on me now um and i can't
believe that's how you're doing it
they're handing you the money at the end
well let's let here listen i did have i
did have about 20 more but like i said
i'm doing better and i went to pretty
main jair on the way here
i know exactly what one you went to yes
sir i stuck a buffalo mozzarella
meatball sandwich right up my ass
um
i have i would guess i have something i
would say about about 40 bucks in cash
that's all right it's not bad i try to
leave the house now that i we i have the
money i try to leave the house with a
hundred have a hundred on me that can
get you out of hey the card machine's
down right right hundred cash got some
twenties but sometimes i just don't have
cash
um a guy came the other day to drop to
take some we got some furniture from
raymond flanagan other furniture for
another room that wasn't good so we were
replacing that last show in boston shout
out right yeah exactly [ __ ] rainbow's
making a killing off me
but i didn't have a way to get points i
didn't tip i couldn't tip the guy no
cash in the house so i then mowed a tip
that's fine yeah that's a dude the
barber shop i go to just
if you're paying with a card you can't
add it on the card cash only if you
don't have cash they just have they just
pulled their memo venmo nice yeah it's
the best best way to do it going the
extra mile like that you got to do it
baby
but uh now i don't know if you did this
in the city i don't think so oh uh do
you tip the mailman slash garbage man
during the holidays garbage man you got
to hit up the mail the mailman i don't
tip because i never really see them but
the garbage man you got it in the city
like at your mom's apartment you guys
were tipping the the sanitation guys no
no in staten island right yeah oh yeah i
know in brooklyn i never tipped the
garbage guy once but sent out i told you
what did i tell you on my podcast what
happened this okay so the garbage man
very first day
first week or whatever i lived in the
house you know tell neighbor tells me
when to put the garbage out i put it out
he leaves one garbage bag in the garbage
pail oh and then he's going away he's
driving down the block and he stops to
do the next house and i said oh
sir i'm sorry i was like you know you
you left a guardrail he goes come here
come here come here so he goes bring the
bring it bring it so i bring it and i'm
like i'm so sorry man it's a black bag
black can sorry i must have missed it he
goes you just move in i was like hey
goes oh hi i'm joe i'm the garbage man
over here i go oh yeah hey i'm chris
here just for me he goes yeah it's a
nice neighborhood i go yeah he goes
listen help me we'll help you oh that's
all he said and then i [ __ ] put the
bag away so that i talked to my neighbor
he's like hey you you gotta agree so you
need to hit them off on holidays and
monthly he's riding holidays and monthly
in the white house yeah
he's riding around the truck with him
yeah
making pickups yeah
really so it's been established it's
been established listen i don't mind
because i hit him off and i said thanks
for everything you know it's it's nice
to be you know when did you hit him off
right there the next week the next
weekend
i saw him i gave him a hundred he was
like oh you don't have to do that but he
put it right in his pocket
oh you shouldn't have huh yeah i was
like
i backed
not only are you ready for this not only
are my bags of garbage thrown out my bat
my cans are put back
on to my property yeah really yeah not
all the way in but you know back onto my
driveway which nobody else gets that wow
could get to a point where you got him
bringing him up to drive yeah dude then
you really know a little bit more who's
running the [ __ ] show over there
exactly i think mailman growing up in
the burbs uh we would leave an envelope
in the mailbox for him around christmas
there you go so they pull it it just
says like you know there's no there's no
stamp on it so he's got to take a look
yeah i feel like we didn't feel like we
did like mickey d's gift cards or
something like that something but you
got it dirt balls mickey d's gift cards
what the [ __ ] it's the holidays you want
cash those things were hot in the 80s no
i don't know what you were talking about
i got i was like bitcoin back then dude
my friend who's a super and i'm sorry
who's a doorman in the building
supers no the doorman clean up said this
super
he said the supers you they make money
like without like he said he said he
thinks some supers might make fifty
thousand dollars in some buildings dude
i thought you buy the balls that was
really [ __ ] [ __ ] next year my my old
job that i had before uh this took off
was [ __ ] uh i worked i represented we
worked at a law firm the representative
international builders and i handled
their properties so i would have to pay
all the doorman all like the porters all
the [ __ ] whatever
dude some some buildings like some
people would make like 500 bucks a
person right and you gotta there might
be you know 50 units in the [ __ ]
thing yeah that's 25k cash just cash out
the door money in your pocket i do two
for my super that's where i'm at too
since we've since we've lived there it's
been two every christmas we give two
comes january around january 1st
christmas you got to go early maybe now
i go i go like i'm [ __ ] ammed up i
can't yeah january on the third send
them to france yeah
you like scotland
yeah no no supers for me to grease right
now nope that's good
anthony's going to want his taste around
christmas
what he deserves
that was real ominous yeah yeah
see how the windows play out all right
this one's a home run that i never
thought about this is from ryan ever use
a cart at a walgreens or cvs
dude if you're buying
if you're buying that much [ __ ] at a
[ __ ] pharmacy it's a bad luck no dude
never i'll walk around my little basket
that's it dude no if i go into cvs i get
my amoxicillin i get the hell out
all right
i'm in and out baby oh cart holy their
carts are real nice though because
nobody [ __ ] yeah they've never been
used oh dude carpet what are you doing i
mean what are you getting at
okay
i mean i mean no dude i've never used i
don't even think i really i'm not even i
get even my food shopping it's all i go
i all get it delivered now yeah
everything's delivered
i don't do it anymore i went to trader
joe's the other day i didn't even know
what the [ __ ] to do yeah i mean they
don't even have like it's everybody's
working at a register there's like 30
registers there you go to like pods and
then they don't let you take the
groceries out and put on the thing like
don't touch your groceries i'll do it
yeah really wow they take it seriously
over there trader joe's does take it
seriously pretty tight operation to be
honest i respect i got keto ice cream
it's about 240 calories so it's too much
yeah
and they come up with their own little
like snacks that they it feels like they
make their lives it's all walking yeah
yeah do it nice they do it nice trader
joe's is nice i got i go to the one on
staten island but delivery that's that's
the pinnacle that's the movie do you tip
an amazon driver amazon no do you amazon
where do you catch them i never see them
yeah i rarely catch them i got something
to deliver this and a lot of times they
don't even hang around like this morning
i got something dropped off they just
hit the bell and that's it they look
good but where you're at there might be
a guy
it might be like it might be his city
it's [ __ ] nine million people yeah my
ups driver um
can you see him on the rack i see him on
the right he thinks i'm andrew schultz
that's who he thinks he's like andrew
schultz man he goes huge fan i love you
since guy code keep doing what you're
doing i'm like absolutely that's who i
am [ __ ] dude that's so funny yeah you
know he'll give me packages and i'd say
chris and stefan i'll go mr schultz
there you go my friend yeah he's got
yours
definitely i don't want it so he's
probably because it's your alias i was
gonna say that's that's how not known i
am well just think you don't gotta
grease him now because the heat will
come down on schultz yeah that's just
what's a bad look for shelter oh yeah
and the rich get richer yeah it's what
it is there you go
there you go yeah i don't know tip to
you if he's yeah if you know him i mean
like
i think there was a guy his name was
mark for like a [ __ ] a decade in my
house growing up that was he was the guy
who's the guy yeah so you'd see him you
know you got a relationship with him
right yeah right yeah i think um i think
yeah i i'm a big tipper i always i just
think you gotta you gotta tip because
it's like me saving 20 30 bucks does
nothing for my life that already advice
is brilliant yeah you got you got a tip
i go big
big but you're gonna be upside down just
in the tips it's like an italian
restaurant
make no mistake i'm losing the house
i appreciate you guys saw it when you
saw it but i mean i am underwater
you've been there two months he's upside
down in a mortgage did you ever
straighten out the guy in the backyard
with the leaves did you ever make that
neighborhood there was something oh
no we haven't had that discussion yet
but i have but uh but colonel clean told
me he can handle clean
i'll talk to him i'll talk to him
help me i'll help you um one thing i
want to know this isn't this is not from
the listeners do you currently have a
change jar and if so what is it
uh yes i have a we have it we have a
change jar and it is a um uh empty uh
pretzel sticks bottle oh that's pretty
good schneider's uh what's one of those
big it's nice it's one of the big ones
and it's it's not even close it's maybe
even less than 25 but if we get to the
top with quarters
we're talking about
thousands of dollars who gets their
hands on that that's in the kitchen the
yeah the kids got that yeah that's for
the kids college that's classy not what
do you mean nothing no not for now well
i mean it depends how quickly they want
to fill it up i would think you're not
going to fill up in a [ __ ] full arts
coin jar might take 15 years that's true
it's going to take a while i'm working
on a pesto jar and that thing is that
thing's not even ham i got a bottle of
francesco rinaldi you're [ __ ] real
sad in my kitchen right now yeah
does she have a little piggy bank though
does she got a little coin on her she
has a little she does coin how about
this you're ready for this she got her
she lost her second tooth i was in
nashville when she lost her tooth she
got hit for 10 at the tooth fairy at
home when i wasn't there then i was with
my dad her grandpa throws me at 20. then
i threw into 20. the kid made 50 on the
tooth fairy for one dude
significant two very sick prices have
went up significantly yeah that'd make
my whole year when i was a kid yeah yeah
she goes down to one on the leaderboard
i know she goes daddy i can lose so much
money just i can make so much money just
losing my teeth i assume you are already
trying to beat this yeah well the great
depression is coming again so you might
have to i assume your dad spoils her oh
my with the cash and all that stuff so i
mean no my dad might literally my dad
give her you know as a three-year-old he
gave her a christmas card about 300 in
cash i'm like what is this borrowed what
is she gonna put it in her diaper bag
like what the [ __ ] why would you give a
three-year-old three hundred dollars in
cash ah that's [ __ ] awesome he gives
he he only gives cash dude he i stuffed
it in her top pocket he goes for it my
father my step parents have been married
about 35 years on my stepmother's 60th
birthday he gave her five hundred
dollars oh my god they have a joint bank
account
i bet those hundreds were crispy [ __ ]
though chris i was crisp
could you imagine giving your [ __ ] i
was like dad it's your wife not even
flowers he was like that's why she gets
500 it's the big 60. big six so she gets
not even 600 he could have probably
could have made it an even even number
it's crazy it's [ __ ] awesome
you guys are walking through nashville
he's got the big [ __ ] diabetes socks
on he's got the long bed mailman sucks
yankees
ripping farts on broadway in nashville
dying laughing he's like i didn't know
he was geese in tennessee
oh that's a big one growing up we would
say who stepped on the dock
no dude classic classic guy he [ __ ]
you know he looks like a sweetheart of a
man but trash like he's bearish
trash eyes go two different ways
we were trying to get him in cowboy
boots his foot he's like he's like he
can't be he goes up to the guy that
covers he goes you got a 13 wide
they said what it's not a pair of rock
ports yeah he goes he goes i need it
wide and then he tried to put him in a
14 or 15 his foot would not could not
get through the opening
he just gave up he went to hattie b's
and had some chicken
shout out to hattie
that was all right i want to talk about
a chicken sandwich blow your hair back
whole baby there's a question socks
first what do you do when you when
you're getting dressed this was big on
the show yeah yeah yeah this is just a
heated thing you put your pants on first
and then socks or socks and then pants i
usually put my socks and then pants on
especially because i gain a little
weight sometimes if i put my pants on
and they're tapered at the bottom i
can't get the sock on because i like my
sock is underneath my pants you know
what i mean sure so if i i need to have
the sock on first cause it's a struggle
to get the pants on i can't struggle to
get the pants on and then have to figure
out my socks
yeah so i go socks on first usually
socks first very very there's been a
couple you and but but i will tell you
this the first thing i ever put on is my
shirt so i wouldn't want these you daffy
duckies
no you don't i swear
[Laughter]
and even jasmine has been like this is a
little strange you always put on your
shirt you look like a big toddler that's
so weird especially if you get caught up
doing something the phone oh yeah oh
yeah you're flopping around oh yeah i
put my shirt on i go shirt on here's
what i do first i'm walking around like
jen anderson i put my chain on i put my
chain on you don't sleep with the chain
on no i take it off i can't get away me
too i take it out yeah i can't get it
wet i want to get a big i love it in the
shower i just can't sleep but it'll
choke me i had a chain i put i put as a
joke i'm like hey when the patreon hits
whatever i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
this chain and he slid in my dms and
goes oh i got the guy for you and sent
me a link yeah i bear real barely ever
talked before i got the guy back
i want that name because i want to i
want to get one a little bit thicker i
got you baby all right
i got my chain guy so the chain goes on
first so chain goes on first then my
shirt then i'll put on my underwear then
my socks then my pants then my shoes
that's that's that's all normal except
for the the shirt first is weird huh
yeah why what about you know there's
another thing i do which is very dumb
and i know this when i take a shower for
some reason
the first thing i do is i wet my
washcloths
i put put soap on the washcloth and then
i immediately wash my [ __ ] yeah but
then i wash my body with that wash and
i've done it i've done it countless
times and i've always been like this is
a stupid thing to do yes but my mind
just says well we're doing it yeah still
doing it yeah
you go washcloth not a scrunchie old
school scrubby in there no gloves and i
said this on my podcast and i genuinely
did get a ranch for a while i was
washing my body with a scrub daddy which
is no good oh i know exactly what you're
talking about it gets when it gets wet
it gets soft it's for the dishes yeah i
saw it on shark tank and i thought it
was a [ __ ] loofah yeah but it's for
the dishes it's a kitchen item he's got
a scotch brite still in his face well no
i got i had a i had a huge brillo pad
yeah sos pad it's a good exfoliator no
that's what happened i started to get
like a like a groin rash not that i
thought it was an std or anything i was
with my girl but i went to a
dermatologist i was like what's going on
here cooking and it was like what's
going on you know he's like you know
talk what's your bathing technique and i
said i'd wash myself with with that that
smiley face luffa thing again no thing
that's easy to clean forks with he go he
goes what are you talking about i got
the the luffa the washcloth loofah thing
that has a smiley face so i i google it
dermatologist friend of mine google it
and the first thing that pops up is
scrub daddy he goes do you wash yourself
with a scrub daddy i said yeah he goes
um that's for kitchenware dude he was
like the it's too brisk the it's too
rough that's yeah you're irritating the
skin the washcloths are softer so for
about six months i was washing myself
down with a scrub daddy this guy's using
[ __ ] oven cleaner in the shower
probably gets in there though yeah it's
good
[ __ ] yeah i do the gloves and a
loofah yeah scrunchy yeah i can't wash
cloth yeah yeah and how about this you
know you kind of surprised that's
the house what kind of soap you're
cooking with what do you use what soap
you use it's got to be something nice um
like a gel or a bar or whatever no i i
never use a bar i go body wash and i go
to three in one i like to get it all
done in one chocolate chip
dish body wash trash i know my skin's a
little dry
i assume jasmine has separate things no
jasmine's got a whole thing yeah
jasmine's got a corner we have two sinks
in the bathroom now and we got two heads
in the one shower so she she's got her
side that i'm not allowed to go here and
i got my side really yeah she's got yes
she says all that but i did see you
don't run them both when you're in there
if i'm in there alone i'm running them
but oh no yeah i mean well no well we
have well no no i mean her side of the
sink like we got two sinks i can't go on
her side uh do i put on both i probably
have um steam it up and steam it up a
little bit yeah
but what she did what she did a couple
of days ago is she you were running out
of toothpaste and she cut the toothpaste
that's and i'm like you can't do that
where we're living anymore yeah if they
knew we were cutting the toothpaste i
mean i already you know ever since our
episode when i said i put my
toothbrushes in the snapple bottle i
threw away the snapple bottle yeah so
that was standard operating procedure
multiple cops what copy yeah i've never
saw that until i got older
they would do that that's what she did
you rub it on this corner or whatever to
get to sure but yeah those things back
in the day those like cane openers that
you would twist yeah you go in there and
you crank it
twisted up the tube of toothpaste yeah
yeah yeah no she that's what that's what
we're doing i told you when we moved she
brought some condiments from the old
house into the new house which i thought
i thought really started off with bad
energy but yes
yes
yes that was tough that was but also she
was looking at him she's like this isn't
trashy i'm like no you're right i'm
sorry yeah no you can't tell she's
intimidating she's very entertained i
know cathedral ceilings yeah i know
that's what she wants and it's like you
know forget it we got to bring in the
hvac guy we got to bring in the roof guy
we got to bring all these guys you're
raising a part of the roof on your house
yes that's serious that's [ __ ]
have to rewire all the duct work for the
eight for the hvac central air stuff now
who figures that out she brings in a she
brings in a contractor this is what you
need yeah she's she's got a guy nice so
that she's probably sleeping with
what can you do who cares at the end of
the day it don't matter hey knock a
couple jihads off and i'll be all right
honestly seriously yeah if it would save
me doing the saturday 4 pm go ahead
uh this is a perfect segue this is from
uh james ever brush your teeth with your
finger oh brush my teeth with my finger
i would say
honestly
more times than not i do use a
toothbrush i would say though i've
brushed my teeth with my finger
500 times not in the house not at your
house this isn't a
desperate situation oh you're saying
brush my teeth with my finger at my in
my own house when i have it anywhere oh
yeah no never at the house if i go okay
you know speaking of teeth dude i hadn't
got a dental cleaning yesterday yeah i
walked out in the middle of it i've
never had more pain at a dental cleaning
the dentist said we didn't even get 30
of the way to your teeth i said sir i
can't do this anymore i'm in
excruciating pain so he said all right
you got to come back they're going to
have to numb my mouth with the shots
just so i can get a cleaning that's how
sensitive my teeth are holy [ __ ] black
build up are you flossing
i haven't
i swear to god i'm i haven't flossed i
don't think i've flown since obama was
president that's the last great
president it's the only thing i do
every tooth you floss every single day i
do it twice a day when do you do it i do
it in the morning my mouth doesn't feel
clean unless i unless i do i feel like
the brushing doesn't do anything unless
i floss but when you floss do you have
does things ever come out of your teeth
yeah not if you do it run on the reg i
get you get gunked up yeah you get black
but like how but like also floss also
removes plaque it's not just your teeth
like it takes the plaque out in between
yeah what do you go in between each
tooth go in between each tooth for
[ __ ] wrap it up i mean how long does
it take to floss two minutes not even
really yeah i don't know every time i
floss i believe if you started doing it
on the regular you wouldn't bleed as
much so floss is for plaque not just
items stuck in your teeth yeah it's not
just like you have a poppy seed to get
it it's supported regular dental care
well i didn't know that so now i'll
floss
this guy
i'm telling you guys a big one at that
he got 50k in windows and i'm gonna
[ __ ] pull out one of the floss guy
starts fleecing he's coming in three
hundred for flaws i'm telling you get
the oral b
um it's called glide yeah those things
are nice and like it's just a little
pick and it just it's like orgasmic it
just pops right up in there easy
no
i don't do anything with my teeth other
than brush them occasionally with my
finger
let me ask you this is this garbage we
got the front of my house painted white
but not the side we left the side the
original color of the brick is it
garbage the it's brick you painted the
brick you painted the we painted the
brick in front of the house white but
the side of the house is still that red
i think that's okay because most most of
those suburban homes
that's yeah i think that's why the front
is like one thing and then the size it's
not garbage because you know like what
somebody said behind the fence too isn't
it it's behind the fence but you can see
it from the street but it's like you
know when people put you know stucco and
all these beautiful rock formations on
the front and the sides vinyl panels
yeah yeah that's garbage that's right
that's my yeah grow that's what we have
brick in the front and then it's vinyl
siding on the side so is that trash
though yeah i mean it's not yeah it's
not it's four colors yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think that's okay i think
you're a natural brick
yeah okay
all right um what's that gonna cost you
you gotta get that painted oh god i
don't know 10 grand whatever it is
you'll see you'll know what i'm doing
when i start putting more shows on sale
uh all right this one i uh this is from
sean this is just funny you ever uh jack
off with your shoes on jack off with my
shoes on i would say most of the time i
jerk off with my shoes on right yeah
most of the time
no what are you doing
what's going on
aren't you on the couch or in bed or in
the shower i'm trying to think i think
most of the time
where are you jerking off that's a good
point yeah well i'm not allowed to i
mean jasmine doesn't let me so
i guess most of the time i'm jerking off
he's in hotel rooms yeah i guess not i
always have my socks on though right i
can't do that what do you got naked to
jerk off sometimes i will yes really
uh-huh like feeling sexy huh
that's [ __ ] weird i won't even pull
down my underwear i just let it i just
pull my underwear down underneath like
the band underneath your balls pop it
off like a push-up bra yeah 100 i'm just
trying to get the work done i'm not
trying to get in and out get this over i
can't just get this
i don't really jerk it i ha i lay it
down against my body and i rub the base
of it and then i shoot it into my belly
button
talked about this i do a thing where i
just rub the tip of it yeah that's what
it is yeah because it's sometimes a full
jerk it's exactly i didn't grow up that
way i wasn't taught that way
what am i working out here yeah yeah
dude you get completely naked you put on
music and candles no i won't i don't i
wouldn't say i get fully naked this guy
jerks off like a divorcee
but i think likes to feel sexy laying
down in a bubble bath
tay i draw a mean bath
you don't jerk off in a tub i have ew
recently i haven't gotten in the tub in
years i got a great tub guy yeah 35
grand i'll give you a thumbs up give me
tough no i'm big i'll still do yeah
tubby tonight hold it in the [ __ ] not
not i mean not probably waiting in your
own soup probably decades ago
um
i didn't know you had creamy kippy
i didn't know you had this little
kicking yeah
i like it turned on to be honest yeah
kippy's [ __ ] hot
[Laughter]
i like a knife give yourself a bath next
time i'm gonna do it it's a it's nice
you've got a tub in there right now we
gotta tell well yeah for the kids we
gotta tell they they go top crazy no but
in your
tub
they got tub fever these dude
and your master bathroom you guys got
like a jacuzzi tub right oh what do we
got what do we got yeah uh no no no no
we don't no we don't i don't have a
jacuzzi tub no we got it we got a
stand-up shower and then we got a little
that little bench you know yeah
just prepare yourself that's going to be
getting rectified at some point
jacuzzi's got to get installed somewhere
100 do you think about a hot tub outside
sure oh yeah no it's all well here's the
thing i'm gonna get hit you know it's
the winter time but that's when you get
hit for the pool we've got a a rock
formation we got to hope you're doing
like the we're doing that [ __ ]
well i don't want to do it well that's
when they're going to put the jacuzzi in
because that's what i was going to say
that's your worst nightmare how much
should i get what what's the expectancy
if we want to rock rocks around the pool
where do waterfall in a jacuzzi what
what am i looking at you're adding that
on to the destruction
structure of the body forget it yeah
yeah like a hundred thousand dollars not
a hundred my brother just no yeah no not
what you're bringing in mason concrete
guys so what do you get oh and and and
dirtbags from staten island too so what
what what what are we looking at another
50 pro i mean yeah i don't i mean i
don't have the blueprints in front of me
so i can't make an educated guess but i
would say
better not have a water pipe under there
buddy i'll tell you that well listen
we're in trouble i would think that a
healthy percentage of these fans are
pool guys so please dm me christy comedy
yeah and just let me know if you can
actually do it for me i'll let you come
on the patreon that's pretty good that's
it you want to come on the show yeah
i'll let you i'll let you teach area
will bang you in the ass just give me a
good deal on my pool best case scenario
you get the you get the the one by
itself over in the corner by the
standalone like that standalone you
start adding onto that pool that's trash
because you can oh you're saying to add
a jacuzzi into the pool that's what i
thought you were talking i thought we
were talking about a standalone jacuzzi
no that's trashy you can't do it
standalone's trashy but i'm saying if
she's already making moves on the rocks
getting the rock formation getting a
jacuzzi added onto that pool is not far
behind but how do you add a jacuzzi onto
an already existing pool yeah i don't
know if they have the space for that too
that that's a lot of [ __ ] you think
now you're talking about digging the
ground like you're talking about what
i'm talking about you should throw if
you're if you're in your sun room or
whatever you call it your florida room
what do you call that room we call it
the sun room the sun room it's nice
on the one side opposite side of the
pool you could put it over there or no
don't you have the space down by the
other end of the pool or go front yard
be real trashy let them know no
no let them know
you want to start pissing in the
neighbor's yard i'll show you how to
[ __ ]
this plate show what's up i'll ruin all
your property values i love it
a red bull hot tub in the front yard
hell yeah dude
yeah get a grill uh
all right we got to do a couple more
here uh this is from uh breaker cassidy
uh you or anyone in your family ever
work at a mall kiosk
nobody none of us ever worked at a mall
kiosk no my i my job i was i was a court
attendant slash ball boy at the u.s open
uh what yeah dude you were a boss they
have to be queen's kids right
all of them yeah all of them are queens
brooklyn
yeah like every part of the allure and
like everybody else running around in
the short shorts well like the french
open or wimbledon it's all like the
elites children like it's like but
by us in in in flushing queens us opens
all [ __ ] firemen cops
kids we're just dirtbags running around
with our accents don't know anything
about tennis oh dude yeah no i've seen
dude you you name a men's player that
was big in the early 2000s i seen their
[ __ ] because i used to load up i used to
load up the ice in the men's uh bathroom
cooler so i mean roddick's dick roger
federer back and they're probably
packing packing yeah um uh rafael nadal
when he was kind of i think he was a
miner i mean but i still took a peek
arrow piece yes you were a miner too it
didn't matter yeah that's true it's a
good point you were an actual ball boy
you you so you could have been on tv no
well i was the court attendant mostly so
court attendants if you look if you
watch your tennis match they're sitting
behind the players with like you know
i'm the one that would come up with an
umbrella i'd always make sure that the
the coolers are stocked uh or that they
have their towels but dude i got up to
the point i got up to the point where i
became like one of the top court
attendants i got a match on arthur ashe
stadium like i got a semi-finals like
match and i sat there and [ __ ] nailed
it which
jeter jersey did you wear for that one
got that in the spring trainers oh my
god dude yeah
[ __ ] guy white socks pulled up that's
[ __ ] great yeah dude i was a good
time man look at that that was pretty
good us open i i did that job and then i
didn't really have too many jobs you
know i ran into physical therapy um but
but but uh yeah the us open man that
that was the job and i mean dude the
schemes they had running i mean i could
imagine you know selling you know all
sport was the big sponsor i mean these
guys were offloading all sports uh you
know selling them to competitors outside
the stadium
then you know fudging the repo i mean
absolute criminal right
the drink like a gatorade it was shacks
but it was like gatorade soda and they
were like the big sponsors yeah it had
carbonation in it yeah which tastes like
code red or whatever i mean dude the
tennis players were falling down with
cramps yeah because you're guzzling
gas bubbles and then playing a sport
yellow number five in there yeah dude i
saw the craziest thing i ever saw and
this is i saw this like it was this is
not i probably google it there was a
player from belgium okay
now
the u.s opened the man you got to win i
think it's three sets right you know you
know so and it's you know each one to
six six love six love six love and then
you know whoever with the third set oh
i'm sorry it's it's best of three so if
you win two
it's over whoever gets to pretty much
two first wins right so
six love he wins he wins all he wins the
first set the guy doesn't score a single
point six left six left six left all the
way through second one
does guy does not score a single this is
a professional us open tennis match on
the side courts but it was a sanctioned
professional match for the uso six love
six left six live it's like the last
set before if he loses this one he's
over literally guy sits down i'm the
court attendant sits down brings his
manager says something in belgium
manager comes over with a pack of
cigarettes the guy lights up a [ __ ]
cigarette and starts smoking a cigarette
it turns around and goes i'm getting my
ass handed to me start smoking a
cigarette and just literally smokes an
entire cigarette now two penalties
because like you have to come out
doesn't give a [ __ ] smokes it puts it
out on the floor literally the guy the
guy serves it the guy [ __ ] takes a
[ __ ] whiff at it like not even close
throws the racket up puts his bag leaves
like this is my favorite player of all
time crazy i was like this guy's uh even
the other player was hysterical what the
[ __ ] it was one of the funniest things
i've ever seen dude a guy was sucking a
cigarette on a us open he's a
professional tennis player that's
[ __ ] it was great that's your guy
right demolished dude
just being like hey i need a minute
straight in my head yeah figure this out
dude
i mean all sporting a marlboro dude the
us open mascot was a big tennis ball and
i'll never forget this kid i think his
name was andres you guys hit him with
batteries no so we put he puts on the
tennis we were [ __ ] around this guy
you guys all know each other we all know
each other yeah we're working at the usa
but for years this guy was like a you
know legitimate friend of ours we find
out
underneath there was practice chords
called p1 through p7 and that's where
they would store you know
caps and bottles and racks all that
stuff and we found the us open tennis
costume just was down there so we had a
long day the kid put it on we're like
joking around whatever you know we had
like a little like um like a stick you
know but like a pole and we were hitting
him with it on the side it was funny and
then pat finger my boy patty fly balls
comes out of nowhere and hits him over
the head that was a soft spot knocked
unconscious laid out
i swear to god with the tennis ball and
we should like fully unconscious
like that just hit the ground i mean
fully laid out with the hands with the
mittens
his feet turn yeah oh dude fully [ __ ]
knocked unconscious in the tennis
costume and we didn't know for about a
minute we were like oh my god we thought
he was just like playing dead and you're
like oh no
[Laughter]
yeah that is too funny all right let's
do well let's do one more here and then
call it a day what time is it uh
4 45 oh we're good you're good
all right
uh this is from kemper uh have you ever
bought a grocery store birthday cake
just for yourself and it wasn't even
your birthday grocery store birthday
cake just to myself and it wasn't even
my birthday have you ever bought a cake
by yourself just yourself yes and what i
do is what i i think i might have told
you what i'll do is when i buy a cake or
when i buy you know a lot of food i'll
say oh you know like you know normal
items an individual buy i would say you
know oh you know i i got a birthday cake
you know let me get up i would say oh
can i get can i get a cake it's uh you
know this is a single chrissy single
christy i'm by myself and say hey can i
get a cake you know i'll take the black
forest uh uh black forest cake yeah yeah
that's good and then you know what oh
what else did she say she wanted let me
get a black and white cookie rainbow
cookies you know with the cookies with
the fudge on it let me do that and then
i'll take a couple iced coffees i'll do
that i'll i'll always open that's big on
this show we've talked about that well
maybe i do have to drive through yeah
that's what i'm saying so so we make
believe we always do that i have a
family of twelve according to my right
hand
in the in the greater
school i'll tell you what i did do and i
i remember this it wasn't it wasn't a
full cake but i ate a a cake that was
already in the house already but it was
about half of the cake i sat down with
my on my lap i was watching sportscenter
maybe a couple years ago had the cake in
still in the box all my left it was for
somebody's birthday the day before in my
house on the cake realized i filled up a
glass of almond milk because i'm
watching when i eat i filled up a glass
of almond milk
trying not to do dairy
and i forgot that i forgot a utensil and
i ate the entire cake with my hands i
have children the whole family by god i
had the entire cannoli cream cake with
my hands and gotta be honest it was one
of those moments that i i i don't regret
yeah just like yeah yeah i was living in
the apartment at the time there were
already roaches so i said what's the
[ __ ] difference i imagine now you're
going nice bakery and stuff like that oh
you're not doing the grocery store
you're a sweet guy right i'm big on
sweets i'm big big big on sweets
cholesterol through the roof sugar
through the roof yeah i'll curse you one
foot
[ __ ] wheelchairs chrissy wheelchairs
baby but you know what when if i go out
like that i'm gonna go out i'm gonna go
out you know class live my life i'm
having fun i'm not depriving myself i
love it big fan of that i do when i'm
ordering my i'll order two bake i'll
order two breakfast sandwiches okay so
i'll go i need a bacon egg and i go can
i have a bacon egg and cheese and then i
do that pause of like that i'm thinking
and i need a sausage egg and cheese as
well how about this i was walking around
i did jim and sam this morning and i was
walking down to go do barn stores about
a 30 block walk down a rough 20 30 block
walk i walked right down sixth avenue
stopped at one of those um you know
breakfast uh you know cart carts on the
corner silver ones i got a yeah someone
will do it they do it
i got a nino special which was bacon
eggs home fries in a wrap salt pepper
ketchup with iced coffee sat down on the
steps of the fox news building
or i like to call it home
so it's always a little bit warmer on
that side of the street on that ate it
had a great time walked about another
two blocks stopped at another cart got a
black and white cookie and a second iced
coffee new york new york city baby
that's what it is but nothing wrong with
it well i said i said i met my day i
said i'm gonna hit about five thousand
steps between the are you garbage kids
the comedy seller this to that i said
i'll burn off this black and white it's
like it's it's like i didn't even eat it
by the end of the day well will you do
something in the subway in your history
would you would you would you ever pull
a trigger on a churro down there no i've
never gained subway food the thing that
just that one it only had happened once
but i never will eat food again on the
subway because i had gotten it i had a
believe it or not a subways tuna
sandwich that i was about to eat and the
man sitting across me homeless man took
off his shoes and socks and it was
disgusting and started pouring hydrogen
peroxide on his feet and i just watched
pus bubbles come out of every piece of
his foot and i said you know what i'll
never even attempt to eat food on the
subway again i haven't been on the
subway since the pandemic have you guys
uh i did up until
probably six months ago i got a i got my
car and then that's kind of when i
stopped you can't i mean have you been
on it he takes it every day yeah i was
on it today is it disgusting or is it
normal now does it feel like old times i
have no barometer for that i'm a huge
piece of [ __ ] yeah oh so you never took
it before the panel no i did it it
doesn't seem any different to me i also
like mess and filth like it doesn't
register with me but it's packed now
like a rush hour it's like it's packed
like it always was yeah yeah for sure
wow not like it always was no there's no
it's not i'm out i got you no it's not
like it always was it'll get crowded but
like it's not
yeah it's not like [ __ ] rush out i
can't protect myself down there
everybody has this i was gonna say there
is no rush hour anymore at five o'clock
everybody's nobody's working from the
building no no it's all empty i would
mandate people coming back to the
buildings i think we need to mandate
that i think my buddy works for like jp
morgan or whatever and he they said the
same like you have until like whatever
the date was yeah you have to i mean at
this point it's like you know get the
city bumping again yeah dude you know
you can't work from home you're not a
[ __ ] child
and no more summer it's like give up
dude
give it up
you're an adult then you go spring to
winter that's how it works the kids do
the summer i don't do the summer yeah
that's kid that's children's [ __ ] that's
hope yeah but it's getting dicey around
here i saw a guy get mugged like [ __ ]
three weeks ago so are you fronting your
face yeah down the block right after in
daylight i know it was no it was
probably ten o'clock nine o'clock what'd
you see guy ran up on it was an older
guy kid ran up on him threw him on the
ground took his bag and
took a lot of h on the block too yeah a
lot of h some of it not too bad
shout out shout out shout out officer
will i saw this and i saw this maybe he
was 13 14 years old i was going my
friend well i had a friend he lived
above a store
so he would leave his bike outside of
like you know uh like against the store
it's like you know pretty busy traffic
kid comes by
steals the bike turns the bike around is
riding down the block i was coming down
from the other way i see them bike being
stolen i froze a little bit i didn't
know what the kid was a [ __ ] pretty
big kid
what am i gonna do so
literally i see officer will going you
know like like walking towards just
randomly just he knew all the kids in
the neighborhood he was like he taught
some programs in the school and he saw
the whole thing but i didn't know he saw
the whole thing he saw it as i mean just
calm walking as if he didn't know
anything and then as soon as that kid
got within an inch he [ __ ]
clothesline and i i've watched this
kid's head smash off the concrete like a
basketball street justice baby yep and
then i'm talking about him writing
[ __ ] handcuffs he was one of those
guys he would go off duty with the
handcuffs
that's how you know yeah you ran into
the wrong option
you're like what the [ __ ] handcuffs and
then my my friend got his bike back and
that's it but you know what it's one of
those things it was still again pre-911
is just a different place got hand we
watched the whole thing kid got
handcuffed put in the back of the police
car he must have been young 15 16 years
old instead of throwing him in jail made
him come out and apologize to everyone
and then they said let him go home nice
i was like nice dude i had a cousin a
uncle of mine worked for the atf and he
got home and he had us still had his gun
on him he's walking the dog down the
street and these kids who came by
playing mailbox baseball and they were
he they clipped like five coming down
the street yeah just like hanging out
the window knocking and dude he just
waited till they got close and they
pulled up dude he [ __ ] was just like
get the [ __ ] out of the car like i'm so
sorry sir
he's walking a poodle at the time
the cuffs is crazy having the peace on
you is one thing yeah but you got the
cuffs you're looking for trouble because
i think you're like
i think he had cuffs no peace i mean
this guy was waiting to make a citizen's
arrest
oh my god ladies and gentlemen mr chris
the stefano baby buddy what do you got
what do you got cooking once it's coming
out this will come out monday monday all
right so christy comedy.com i'm gonna be
in uh durham north carolina uh
co-headlining with sal uh volcano good
times then november fourth to the sixth
salt lake city november 21st uh laugh
boston's all sold out we added two we
got two shows at the wilbur
second one at eight o'clock i was almost
sold out we added to 5 p.m go get
tickets for that and then we got to
borgata we got big shows at the end
december 26 to the 31st we're going me
and sal are going to texas and [ __ ]
cincinnati i'm doing new year's eve in
cincinnati baby columbus big market yeah
big market so we're gonna be around and
then uh whole save the date february 5th
save the date big new york city shows
going on sale soon save the date baby
uh guys come to uh our live shows we
have uh
philly and new york we have upstate new
york all those tickets are available get
them now both of those shows in new york
are going to sell them the tickets are
running low so make a [ __ ] move what
do you guys do in new york gotham comedy
oh local boys make good and then
philly's punchline healing what do we do
we're in helium company here it is yes
sir love it gang we love you we'll see
you next week peace